I was born in a wig store oh yeah wait
what okay yeah my I grew I was born
inside literally a wig store yeah and my
my cradle is that what they call them
cradle crib crib I call the Cradle the
Cradle cuz of the
lullab from the old Levis and U my
cradle was in the mannequin storage room
not creepy the broken ones God not
creepy so there was like 50 like
mannequins staring down at me right and
I'm a little baby oh my God yeah
that's why you're scared of white people
that's great white over whole time
that's right that's right you're so
scared man that's why I'm so scared
scared of George Bry and Bryce all the
time this guy like hello Bob I'm
intimidated by white people because of
that experience but um we were in San
Diego a week and a half ago and we were
at a taco shop and Bobby was sitting
down and I was ordering at the counter
and a girl excitedly hurried over to me
and she wh Whispers in my ear that's
Steve ioke
[Laughter]
right oh my God that's a compliment
though and I said yeah go say hi to him
oh my God what did she say to you when
she came they were looking at me so I
thought cuz I walked into this car this
taco place yeah they know they know and
then they had left and ran into her and
they were talking outside I could see
and then she laughed I can see her laugh
outside the window the best right and
then she came in she goes you can't
believe just happened they thought you
were Steve if Ste like if Steve AI like
was like ate a thousand
Donuts body and then got like a piano
fell on his head right and he you you
mean he got comp compacted into a Bobby
I mean there's I look nothing like Steve
Aoki that's hilarious I I don't I don't
really know what he looks like he's very
zelt yeah very skinny very skinny do you
ever get people ever say that you they
think you're somebody else or no are are
you Tia Swinton yeah you're so good at
dror strange so good um no they think I
went to high school with them oh they
were like oh do I know my one my one
Asian friend in high
school yeah Roger Chang you know like
very um they think I'm somebody they
know yeah and what do you say do you say
yeah or I I go I don't know I go no I
didn't go to that school no I just no I
didn't go to that school but do you I
mean I sometimes want to go no I'm a
comedian what do you mean like oh just
straight up tell you are yeah but then I
don't because it's weird that's when it
gets weird and I don't like when you do
this we're like where have I seen you
like and they keep digging and digging
and he's reluctant to answer but finally
he he gives him his credits and it's
like o he pulls up his went off the deep
end there he's like look look it's me
and he Googles
himself [__] I never [__] Googled
myself but I have done I have done this
where you go they go what how do I know
you and then I go and I keep throwing
things out yeah they go no no no and
then you never get to like you know
something they know they know and then
it's like well I guess I don't know you
and then then because this weird like
bye so awkward so awkward like I wish I
didn't do that you know so I'm a big
Freckle man myself wa wait those aren't
freckles on your face those are liver
spots did I [__] [__] did I just did I
just [__] where the [__] did George go
he's getting a charger [__] did I say
that I I I counted my own freckles on my
face no because I thought you were
trying to pass your liver spots for no I
F [__] I already said yo yo dog I don't
got liver spots on my face in case you
want to wonder about it what are you all
I think he's I think he's turning up the
hip-hop today like your ha
if you don't know if you're not familiar
with Urban Bobb yo what's up dog [__]
this is a this is a thing he does raise
the roof
dog so get jiggy with it get jiggy with
it pretty good huh to the left to the
right I've noticed like he the door
introduced to like a new slang word like
every episode like I've seen that thing
happen I'm sorry am I I'm sorry guys I
know I'm an old man and I know that no
man I'm watched too bro you are yeah I'm
washed too what does wash mean you see
like I knew that was going to come like
I like what does wash mean I mean washed
is just like washed up you know what I
mean like well like I like people in
hip-hop if you're just like you know
share like old school views and stuff
just be like I'm washed oh that's new
write write it down that's new
terminology we're
learning up okay like in Hip Hop when
you're like 30 you're pretty much
watched right you know what I mean cuz
it's like a youth driven oh give me a
slang that I wouldn't hear and then I'm
going to say um say somebody say
something like hey have you heard of
this and I'm going to say something go
ahead have you heard of washed no I was
going to say I'm washed
oh yeah that doesn't work that doesn't
work yeah yeah do that do that one yeah
hey have you heard of washed n man
washed doesn't doesn't make any sense
yeah it makes no sense you know what
dude you got to go back to improv
classes hey you heard to bup and grind
oh [__] man I don't know about that I
washed that does that work no cuz
bumping grind is like an old school
thing so you wouldn't be washed
understanding that you know what I mean
why bump and grind is already washed mhm
you know mean no to me it's fresh still
frh that's the thing you know what
here's
what really was I how about this what if
I was like I was frozen no I'll give you
example right let's say Bobby Lee was an
Anar anarch doing my hike one of my
hiking Expeditions the ones you do every
summer right and Avalanche comes on top
of me right I free
right and then 40 years later they find
a way to defrost my body right I awaken
right and then they say yo you know
about bump and grind and then I could
say I washed well they would have to
introduce you to the word washed first
yeah and then you would use it referring
to some old [__] I [__] it up right oh
I [__] it all up all right well then
I'm not washed right I understand
everything no no no if you were like a
young kid in the future and you went
back back in time and you used it then
that would then that would work would
work it would work yeah yeah so that's
new termin who makes these up man
honestly like I pretty much just learned
that too like I'm pretty washed too
yesterday you know what I mean but I was
like oh this is something like I could
say about myself you know yeah just
roast myself how about this the last
year what are some new thing terminology
that's last year I want to see if I've
heard of them this past year I don't
know if there's when did woke happen oh
that's like two three years I don't like
using woke I know woke is already
washed it's not washed to be woke but
the word woke and using it is wash like
woke is considered kind of corny at this
point too you know what I mean like okay
I just learned it but okay like if we
said woke if we said woke in front of
black people they'd be like yeah think I
think it's just kind of corny you know
yeah and how about um lit oh my God
that's
so that's white culture now lit's been
around forever and it's still being used
it's I feel like is it just like part of
the vocab vocab now you know what I'm
saying like I don't know I think it
might just I don't even know how to use
it I mean yeah yeah anything can be lit
though it's lit you can say A party's
lit you can say food is lit taking a
bath man it was lit yeah you could be it
could have been a lit bath yeah when
when is a bath a lit bath when you enjoy
it when it was just amazing extra when
it just got input into like regular
terminology when people started using it
like that like damn that key is lit like
you know what I'm saying then everybody
was like oh this [__] is just everywhere
can a negative thing be lit like um oh
man I was at that party that night and
then um I don't know I passed out and I
was in Alleyway and a black guy was
[__] me in the ass it was lit no you
enjoyed it no it I didn't enjoy it I
didn't enjoy I hat it it lit what people
what people would do is some [__] that
like you kind of like it was obviously
terrible you don't want to admit it was
like you kind of liked it so be like oh
man bro I woke up I was in the alley but
it was kind of
lit like it was kind of lit like it was
kind of lit yeah I I hear that a lot
it's kind of lit you know you're going
to kill me if I don't tell you this but
you do have a booger R this can you as a
girlfriend can you take it out yeah I
would try
to why you making eye contact with I had
a friend named uh James Kim in high
school and uh he uh he had one year he
decided he was going he was he wanted to
know how many boogers he produced and so
umle tickle jar tickle jar by the bed
wait so he would dry them roll them and
that's how he roll them and toss him in
the uh the jar I I have logistical
questions about this okay go ahead he
it's not a him but it's not it's not me
no but my thing is sometimes they come
out very wet you could you could
technically roll three out of one right
there's no way to measure unless you
made them all equally equal amount of no
no you're thinking you're thinking
number of boogers he's thinking Mass
he's measuring mass wait yeah and when
you're when you're counting boogers it's
always Mass yeah but it's not I don't
know if you know this John's right snot
versus booger is a very very you know
slippery slope what snot versus booger
sometimes you pull out something and
it's like is this but what you don't
realize is that I don't know why we're
talking about this right now because we
have a [__] star here but like um let
me dive in it
dries oh I know okay it [__] dries
like ice no does ice
dry yeah yeah it dries Like Glue this is
a this is a cliche this domestic
abuse situation happening right here oh
you're right you're right I should be
kind I know you're right you're right
John it is cut it out all right I'm
going to bring him all right let's do
start the thing so we can I can bring
them up yeah someone give me Pap T
booger out her hand because you made her
pick it don't all right this is
disgusting this chaos oh [__] man don't
you feel like Moses and you like were
allowed into Canaan like you got you got
oh I'm going to be wandering in the
wilderness with these bozos
yeah forever and and you thought it
wasn't it was never going to happen the
land of milk and honey was never going
to be available to you I know and I
can't believe we're here I I I I won't
say that everything's perfect right now
but I'm just saying it's like a
different time and it's crazy it's so
much [__] better for me John yeah I
mean I don't want to cry right
now but there was a time John where I
was like I think I'm out I mean she was
with me I I would like wake I would like
a year would go by not a single audition
and I would look at her and this is
after all the [__] that I've done and
I'd just be like I think I'm out it's
kind of why we started this podcast
really he really had you know nothing
going we were like do you think it's cuz
you don't have any Talent do you think I
was think La of talent
Factor no I was I was thinking that but
I think what it was is I made something
that had nothing to do with the
Hollywood Machine yeah right and I
gathered the fans on my own these are
legitimate M you you you had the you you
you organically made the new model for
Hollywood which is you do something
something and then people come to you
and go can I have a piece of that yeah
and whereas before we were going can I
have a piece please may I I
know here's another thing that you did
last thing but um I don't know if you
remember this but we were doing Harold
and Kumar
three do you remember the the um medic
the the guy that did the you remember do
you remember remember I remember was so
pissed I know I cuz that was so funny
because I um brought it up before you
got here I don't if you remember this
but so you remember so what happened was
I asked for like an aspirin or something
yeah to the medic you wanted cuz I think
your trailer was farther away so you
wanted to use my restroom for some
reason so you went in there he came
around the corner this medic and he goes
oh
M your I be prop or whatever yeah God
and I'm on a movie set I don't you know
I'm so desperate to be there right so I
don't want to cause any waves so I'm
like oh hi I guess I'm Mr re yeah he
comes out and he goes looks at the
[__] medic he goes don't ever do that
again
damn and I went oh my God he's my
hero because you did something that I
have always wanted to do but because I
was conditioned to to play along right
with white people when they do these
things that they think they're being so
[__] funny and I don't want to be
confrontational so I just let it go and
I think that that's the wrong
move I uh remember that and um I also
remember thinking because I I'd never
asked for anyone to be fired and I and I
had a discussion I went back and I think
I think I talked to John and Hayden
about it and and we and I talked about
it
one now as I'm recalling I think part
of why I didn't press the issue was he
was from
Europe and they got they they got some
weird sensibility
really they throw bananas on the soccer
field at black players like it's bananas
over there and so literally
sorry funny and so I I I remember going
okay I'm going to I'm going to step back
and and and just to let him know that
this isn't going to be tolerated but
yeah I I was kind of surprised myself I
was like I got really pissed yeah I was
like you what what what are you doing
yeah it was really like crazy the way he
did it like full on like he did the walk
Oh my he did a whole like he did the
whole walk with this thing yeah yeah he
kind of went around the corner oh dude
you didn't tell me that at the time you
would have been fired no but and he did
the whole thing and like I would have
let it go but but you you know and from
I don't think from then on when people
do that I think I say [__] now I go hey
dude that's 80s yeah like at a comedy
club I'll get off people go Mr you're so
funny I go dude bro what are you doing
yeah but before I never said anything I
said that's C white people are crazy so
John are you back for a while now or no
yeah I'm back um I I shot the show in
New Zealand yeah and then um I stayed
and did uh a film there and then
um and then we were there sort of we
waited out the pandemic a little bit put
my kids in school and then um in New
Zealand you did yeah wow yeah uh what a
great place to be during the pandemic
yeah there were covid lists for most of
the time and and then at the end there
we got put into lockdown because Delta
got in um and then we left uh but it was
a it was a really great rest bit for us
um do they speak speak English oh my God
Bobby yeah they do yeah what is your
problem well they they probably have a
native yes the mai the mai is a great a
great language but they they all speak
English I had no idea and I learned
something new oh yeah that's right it is
adna speaks English oh my God Israel
Adisa is also from my Nigeria he's also
from from Nigeria but he has New Zealand
Roots as well right okay so they speak
English yeah but he's not Mai I'm just
letting know Israel not Mai all right oh
my God so you spent the [__] my God
you spent the pandemic at New Zealand
yeah yes at New
Zealand let me guess that City let me
guess guess name one city in New Zealand
o yes close yeah yeah that's I know
there's o uhuh o asz Octon not ashz um
it's not aitz right no it's what's aitz
that's the world Hitler [__] I got wrong
yeah yeah yeah that was wrong yeah
that's way too far that's right that was
that's
inappropriate I'm disappointed I'm so
sorry I should have G there cut that
part out keep it in
but it I'm sorry K go ahead what give me
the the another noun or another sound
you're supposed to guess it Disney o o
it goes o and there's one more syllable
give me can you give me a word that
sounds like it hand
Auckland wow you're that was
wow that was really good are you being
real no I know I don't know all right so
you were in Auckland yeah yeah yeah so
when you're in Auckland and your kids
are going to school there yeah obviously
they speak English I know that because
you know I know yes my kids speak
English I know I speak English I they
speak
English God so do you like Lord of the
Rings
yeah okay how did it
end how I'll tell you how how did it end
I'll tell you how it ended yeah wait you
mean the original
Three no I'm talking about the movie
yeah the movie yeah yeah okay so it
ended by Return of the King right yeah
bro I'm going to tell you how it ended
dude all right so they come back from
the voyage right and my favorite scene
right before it ends is when they're in
Gondor right and then um writer the king
sings
it and then remember that and then he
sees the elf lover Liv Tyler right and
then they do a well first she goes first
they you know she has like something
over her face right and then she CU she
gets shy you know how elves get shy she
got shy and she's like oh no right and
then he he lowers it down and he goes in
like wild for the kiss so that happens
and then they go and they see the
hobbits and and the hobbits when they
see the king Gondor the king of Gondor
they they bow to him and he goes oh no
my friend you know you don't have to bow
to anyone right and then everyone bows
and then when I saw that in the theater
I [__] cried like a [__] baby you
know who cried what me too that scene so
what did you just say right now you just
nailed it right now that's how that's
how Return of the King ended right
that's not how it ended I was I come in
here we haven't even started the show
yet you start hitting me with lord of
the the Rings stuff and I said you watch
Lord of the Rings how did Lord of the
Rings end the hobbits bouted the king
and you're you're trying to make up this
thing like I'm the king right and what
did the king do what he bows to the
[Laughter]
Hobby what is
happening what the
[__] what is
happening you're like like it's like
Gandalf coming in whatever I bow to you
all right and I bow to you I bow to you
because you're the king of condor but
you didn't cry when the when the when
the hobbits bowed to the king you cried
when everyone bowed to The Hobbit why am
I the Hobbit Dogz look at you
dude okay I bow to you all right and I
bow to you King I bow to you and I bow
to you we both bow we bow to each other
bro we all bow to you
because I went on a voyage I don't get
it I'm the one that saved the world I
mean what the [__] is going on here
you're just saying I'm a hobby because
I'm small and have stubby legs that's
[__] up bro that's part of it but it's
it's more than that all right when when
I've saw you park your car come inside
the house and we talked and we're
walking in I literally don't recognize
you I know your face right cuz you're
like you've got like you're a Korean you
have a big head right you got that thing
right but I just didn't know what kind
of Korean I was watching because it's
like you've you're completely different
you've lost weight first of all you look
nice thank you right and your demeanor
is completely different before used to
be like the Tasmanian
devil you know what I mean walking in
the room and now it's like you're just
calm you're very um that's a projection
I'm just going to go ahead and stop that
Dave has never been a Tasmanian devil
you were
that Dave's always been way calmer than
you thank you Kila I appreciate that
you're right you justed yourself to a
tea I was projecting yeah yeah totally
and I again I apologize for that as well
you guys going to be offended if I
ordered Postmates to the house no I
thought we going to go eat afterward I
didn't know if you'd have food here so
there's certain things that don't
deliver to my my house so I I checked
here and I ordered I got I got some for
I know what you mean you're right but
what did you order already he's here
right now can I get it you keep talking
all right what is it oh my God you order
when did you order it before the podcast
I'll tell them some I'll tell him
someone's coming out
okay yeah I ordered it right when I was
pulling in I I just yeah yeah so the
Postmates uh messed
up what's the V see that's not Postmates
oh this the Postmates guy Ste that's not
[__] Sten
you that's that [__] Postmates bro
come on
[Music]
in you know I walked out there I was
like why is that Postmates got look
familiar all right so Steve did you
bring
food yeah yeah you want me to order no
no no let's second mic you'll have to
share very we'll get close Steve Oh wait
we're doing this yeah yeah yeah explain
to Bobby right now why you're here right
now so yeah so Steve Steve came to my
house a few nights ago and we talked for
hours about
you hours it's so uncomfortable I can't
even do it is this an intervention no
it's not an interven it's not so
uncomfortable I can't even [__]
believe it so let me ask you you just
told me I'm so [__] uncomfortable I
can't stand it but can you for a little
bit because he's
here can you be open to hearing what we
have to say yeah you okay can you be
open to hearing what we have to say no
matter how uncomfortable it makes you
yeah go
ahead oh here we go bow number eight
they've been bowing the whole time for
respect oh okay you don't have to you
don't have to gu I'm
um I like that bow that's a new
bow I gotta learn that one all right so
oh listen that's my dad I didn't know
okay okay okay oh my gosh
is is this your for real he's dead yeah
um all right wait okay so you know what
you're uncomfortable no no you know what
I'm going to do I'm what I'm going to do
is I'm going to do this I'm going to
take them my earphones off and then
you're going to close your eyes no I'm
not close your I'm going to put and I'm
I'm going to listen like I ears wow I
want my ears to hear this [__]
[__] maybe close your eyes maybe
close your eyes maybe close your eyes no
Don't Close Your Eyes I don't want to
close look at cuz this is sabotage and I
love it go ahead you think this is s I
don't know what it is let's just do it
okay you think this is a do you want me
to go or do you want to go you go first
I've been talking to this guy mad when I
tell him how much I love him I um can
you can you hear me
everyone's good on the mic you want
headphones oh no I'm okay okay oh okay
really okay I got a m thank you um it's
not that intense I we were just talking
and you know Dave Dave is great because
if you know if you have an idea he
pushes the button and then we're just on
to the idea but basically we were just
talking about you and how
underappreciated you
are and we wanted to come tell you that
like what you talked about yeah what
okay I'm genu genuinely like like we
were we were talking about because I
because I know you're doing a bit
sometimes too is like sometimes I listen
when I listen to tigerbelly the fun bit
that I hear you do is that uh nobody
respects you or your career and that's
not true that's not true especially for
me yeah cuz I massively respect I know
you do yeah I mean I don't know that you
but I you know it's it's funny it's like
let me get back in here wait what
happened to the listening part I just
listen to it can M May respond no I I
didn't I didn't get to say what I you've
been talking for [__] an hour half
true that's true true I want to hear
more I want yeah go
ahead I I can yeah yeah give can I
respect
your here I got your dad my D no I got
him I'm gonna hold him so we start
talking about tiger belly we start
talking about you and
um it's just
uh you know we could you know we could
talk about the Handcuff stuff this and
that but the pain I feel of when I hear
you go into like man I went into this
pitch meeting I didn't get the thing I
used to be on the show called Matt TV
like it's a show from like 20 30 years
ago never really say that and and I just
sit there and I go what you heard what
Steve just said I and I go I wonder if
Bobby know knows what he means to me and
then I say that to Steve and he goes I
wonder if Bobby knows what he means to
us and it's like I I have it all I'm
fine oh no I'm thriving but it's like
everything you've ever wanted every it's
like like do you know what you mean to
me God do you know what
you that's why I asked you are you open
to here and you said you're going to sit
it's not the way I thought I was going
to go look
you walked into cafe 101 and and and you
do the bid oh there's like a warlock
there with nail polish you do the whole
thing and I never ever in my life
thought I would meet you and and and I
never thought I would meet you again
which is why I was like this is my
chance right and you say all this [__]
you changed my brother's life this all
that you changed my life you changed my
life and I I I want you to hear it even
though it makes you uncomfortable
like see why do you got to do that I
don't know why I why do you got to do
that I was
sneezing all right that was a sneeze I
mean are you taking in anything that
we're saying yes I am that's why I
closed my eyes I'm absorbing it but I
get it I
get I can't hear
even I I get the the cringe of this
thing but you know we even talked about
it I was like I don't know if I maybe I
should just call him person
but then you know this is more yeah
intense Hollywood baby but but
truly
Bobby you're like not
you're I think you know this but
sometimes it just feels nice to hear it
like you did it when nobody else
could you did it for us we B to you and
people don't fully
know by himself now by by himself Babe
meet him I don't I know because I I I'm
going to tell you why this is did that
feel foolish thank you
so don't laugh we we we you you did it
but but it's serious but it's Ser
serious don't turn it into a joke I'm
not don't turn you did it you did you
did it I receive it genuinely you did
it receive it i' I've I've absorbed it
inside my body and I'm going to say
something in return and I'm going to be
as authentic and as real as I can be
okay number
one it's the realization that it really
doesn't mean that much at the end of the
day it's like I have everything that I
need okay honestly I do I have a house I
have some money saved up I have a
beautiful girl girlfriend I have friends
my mom's still alive my brother's with
us and he's he's thriving as well so
that's number one number two is I really
be believe that I am owning up to who I
am not just as a human being but also as
an Entertainer okay and I in this last
year it's been very fruitful for me I'm
working all the time and things have
been great and um and I'm going to New
York to do something else you know I
mean next month you know I got sex in
the city right so I'm doing that and I'm
doing you know and I'm so for me when I
hear you guys say that right it's you
know um it really means a lot because
obviously I love both of you I think you
both are in incredibly talented and I
really do appreciate it and I almost got
really emotional emotional there you
know and I I have defense mechanisms and
I
and yeah you're doing it let me can I
just finish yeah because that's your
thing what I don't want to yell don't I
love you you know when I yell at you and
I go tiger belly could be the biggest
show and and that's like
me that's you're right that is that's
that is old Dave but today I just accept
you as like you don't have to be on Sex
in the City you don't have to do any of
that and so I didn't say that just for
you to say that I'm just saying that
look you're getting angry again and I'm
not getting angry I just you to really
understand what but you know you know
what happened to me on the drive here I
was like I need to download some Bobby
So I listened to bad friends your newest
episode so good and then um the
beginning of the episode you were just
recounting how much work you had and
then I almost turned the car around be
like [__] he doesn't need me to come
over here and say this
[__] I was like this is [__] nonstop
what the [__] yeah yeah no you you
things and I you didn't need me to I
just just to be clear yeah this is
awkward for me because I know you don't
need this and this wasn't me this is not
an intervention or us coming here to be
like you feel down on yourself like for
me it's just like we sat there I haven't
talked to you in a while and so now I
get to like tell you in a time
when and I don't want to shrink you down
to just Asian-American but like in a
time when asian-americans are getting a
spotlight just on that lane of what
you've done for the community
Beyond separate from Humanity but what
you've done for that specific Community
massive and people don't get it I and
that's kind of what I want to say is
less to you and more on this program I
don't think people fully realize what
Bobby Lee did for asian-americans so
this [__] this fucker's at my house
we're having this conversation at my
house and I'm like I wish I was better
friends with Bobby so I could call him
right now and he would pick up the phone
and we could tell him on person and and
I said you know what I would what
Steve's telling to me is like making me
emotional and so I'm like I want to tell
this to Bobby but he's never going to
pick up my call I should just go on
tiger belly and tell him and so here I
am now and you're getting and and you're
getting you're getting and and so we
start the show and he goes oh without
DVD I say there's no tiger belly there's
no [__] us without you there's no us
without you that's true that's true I'm
Bruce Lee there's nothing there's a void
there's nothing there's nothing how
about this you know and then there's
Bobby Lee on Mad TV and you're like oh
there's hope there's a light at the end
of the tunnel what you meant to me a
young me what you meant to a young Steve
yeah you know what's great I want you to
hear that 100% 100% I hear that and I
remember an episode of tiger belly where
you tell the story about you guys were
at a Korean barbecue and you're talking
about how like
you are you self-anointed yourself as a
Korean something at parks Barbe yeah at
parks and then you [__] ate it and
that's because it's the shittiest Raw
Deal to have to anoint yourself in your
own mind to the worth that you inhabit
and that's kind of the function that I'm
trying to serve here with Dave is like
let me just give it to you like you got
it like you did it and you did it for us
you [__] did it you did it for us but
you know what though what I'm saying is
your existence is more powerful than you
realize to uh uh like in that you just
doing this [__] show is more stop
Asian hate than anything like you just
being here and being your thriving funny
[__] self is like you don't what were
you going to say don't hurt me don't hit
me yeah you like it when people hit
you you're really offended but that's
but your existence is the protest
and your existence has been the protest
since the beginning of your career and
that's kind of the validation that we're
trying to put out there for you again
not that you need it but just for the
knowledge just like sitting here it's
like Bruce Lee that's not me there's
this Asian waiter guy that's not me and
then and then there's this guy this guy
with the he comes out and I go okay that
guy I got really I got emotional and I
you know the first the third day I was
on Mt TV a producer called me to his
office and he said sit down and I sat
down and he goes when you auditioned I
didn't want you on the show I don't
think I don't think that you're talented
I don't think that you're right for the
show he's a producer on the show and I
go really and he goes yeah it's just
like the owner of the show really likes
you and a couple of other guys but like
I just you know so basically he was
saying like me and my my writing staff
that the people that I probably going to
write you things you know he said don't
take it personally we just you know and
I remember turning around walking out of
that room in just in like in the verge
of tears right
going uh oh this is even when I get
something yeah it's there's another
hurdle and there's another wall I have
to climb yeah and this that one was one
that was like so high up right cuz I had
to change his mind and and when you
don't have the opportunity on the show
right you don't get a lot of screen time
and parts written how are you going to
hit the ball right so it's like it was
it was you know it was tough you know
and I stayed on there I just just showed
up you know I showed up and it was hard
I think you didn't just show up though
you took several years of [__]
beatings and yet you thrived like they
put weights on you and you still thrived
and you're out here now thriving
independent of that yeah yeah and I
wonder
like you know you could take the weights
off
too what a concept
wow wow and that's not an intervention
Point that's for me like as someone that
launched off of your trailblazing and
your shoulders I can say there's a point
at which I was like oh cool I could take
this off I put this I kept this on and
it became a thing I Justified and now I
could take this [__] off
and then you're just like [__] I'm good
like I can do it okay I just you know
you know I don't know what this is but
um what do you mean this guy comes to my
house no I know I know what it is I know
no I'm just saying I I I know what it is
it's just um I wasn't expecting this and
um I you know I appreciate what you guys
just did and this is the first time in
my life where
I agree with you in the sense that like
yeah it was hard and I did do it and I
and they didn't want a Korean guy on the
show they were like we want we need a
white guy cuz it they you know and then
they they tested me and Taran killum and
they're like we want the white guy but
we'll bring the Asian guy just as an
experiment right my point is is that
everything was kind of difficult and um
and I just I always knew like when I'm
at a I'll be honest with you when I'm at
a comedy club and I'm stacked up against
all these white and black guys and this
and that I know know that I can carry my
way and I know that I will be as funny
or funnier than all of them right I
believe that you are I know I believe
that you know I've seen it I've I've
I've done it you know what I mean I've
seen it so all those it's hard to say
because it's like how do you toot your
own horn yeah how do it's it's just a
difficult thing to do you know and
um I um I hear you guys and I really
really that means a lot to me and and I
really appreciate it you know I think
that this was a um we appreciate your
hard work yeah it's really good we see
you yeah are you getting emotional I am
cuz I think that I don't know just like
we've been together a decade mhm and
when I met him he was so broken and he
was so down on himself and he was just
so like lost and he was still like
looking at these Gatekeepers of
Hollywood thinking like hand me
something have I not done enough and
I've just always been like on the
sidelines like desperately trying to
tell him like he's worthy but I'm a
nobody I was just a nurse you know and
I'm just somebody that loves him so to
hear it from you guys you know like
established people like it means a lot
to me cuz I feel like that reverberates
more in him in his body than it would
coming
from you know somebody like me who just
loves him for whatever chaos comes
whatever form or shape shape that he
comes in right and so that means a lot
to me hearing that your words and your
acceptance of the fullness of Bobby as
he is is the most powerful thing that he
can have like straight up my wife is
like she takes me she sees me when I'm
taking
shits you know what I'm saying and she's
still here yeah so so like [__] everyone
else I've seen it it's powerful shits
really yeah man but I I all that to say
like I'm I'm not here to tell you
anything like you already know I'm just
here to tell that's why I think this
public forum is cool because it's like
cool every [__] that didn't
realize that Bobby Lee like set [__] up
for people and us and
took man think I mean I know how hard it
was and still how hard it is is for me
to navigate this industry and you did it
when nobody was there nobody and we do
the the you know whatever it turned into
a bit we're doing the bow joking thing
that's not a joke that's not a joke yeah
I know it's not now I know it's not um I
pay respect listen I you know I don't
want to cry
anymore why not because it's it felt
good it felt good it was a release I
felt good about it and I Le um you know
I um people need to pay respect to you I
I I know and we did
that we did that and I I honestly from
the bottom of my [__] heart thank you
to for doing that I've never that I
never dreamt that people like you guys
like guys I really respect I really do
like in terms of I like I go this these
are guys are younger and I can't even
believe that you know know sometimes you
know I can't believe that certain people
like me whatever it feels good you know
so it's like I want to say thank you for
doing that it's you know so much respect
there and I believe you and I um I'm
never going to forget it I'm never going
to forget it oh shout out to Tia Carrera
that was another one I really oh t love
her you're not the only
one you're not the only one